today we're talking about sigops looker
and the impact of smart load balancing
I'm Ryan and welcome to this week in
Cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news in November our paper
spanner Google's globally distributed
database was selected for the 2022
seagops Hall of Fame award which is an
honor bestowed on the most influential
operating systems papers published by
the organization
check out the blog to learn more and why
this matters for simplification and
scale
marketing strategies based on complex
and dynamic data get results however
it's no small task to extract easy to
act on insights from increasing volumes
and ever-evolving sources of data
including search engines social media
platforms third-party services and
internal systems
that's why organizations turn to sear
interactive they provide every client
with analysis and analytics SEO paid
media and other channels and services
that are based on reliable data by using
looker head to the blog to learn more
reliability of a system can be measured
based on several factors including but
not limited to Performance resilience
and security
nevertheless resiliency is one of the
key factors
in a recent post we focused on the
optimization of network connectivity
performance to Containers hosted on gke
as well as optimize resiliency of
containerized applications with the
direct visibility of a container's
health from an external load balancer
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud